[MUSIC]
I think we often see leadership
development as self-development.
There's the individual level.
That's where we're really
thinking about you as a person.
A good leader understands what she
has to do to make herself develop.
But there's a second level,
that's the organizational level.
A great leader understands and does what
she has to do to help others to develop.
Most leaders are not
running entire companies.
Most leaders are touching
only a handful of people.
Maybe they don't have any formal
leadership authority, but
they do touch their peers and
their colleagues at work.
And those interactions
are opportunities to show leadership.
All of us are challenged
to engage in behaviors that
essentially have leadership
implications for the people around us.
How do your actions as a leader
affect the growth mindset of others?
And then finally,
the third level of analysis is
the environment of the organization.
This includes society, economy, the
broader culture, the natural environment.
The things each of us do
at work not only matter for
work, they also matter for
the broader world.
Because our actions as leaders,
in order for us to be exceptional,
also will have implications
at that third level.
>> Transform your approach to
leadership excellence and development.
Learn more about SEP,
the Stanford Executive Program.
[MUSIC]